Palestinians have marked 75 years since
the nakba also known as the catastrophe
that's when hundreds of thousands of
Palestinians were forcibly expelled from
their homes to make way for the
establishment of the state of Israel as
leader Ibrahim reports from the occupied
West Bank people there marked the day
with protests and cultural events
75 s of waiting
inspired this artwork
Palestinian artists are using new
mediums to talk about their history and
their future
more than 20 Palestinian and
international artists participated in
this exhibition organized on the
anniversary of the nakba
the day in 1948 when hundreds of
thousands of Palestinians were forcibly
displaced from their land so the state
of Israel could be created you're saying
even if they moved away from the refugee
camp
sales refugee yeah and that's why you
see this the sign of infinity it's like
eight because it's ongoing
organized this event for years he's been
his music art to highlight Palestinians
daily struggles under Israeli occupation
I refuse to portray the Palestinian
reality as an alternative narrative it's
all reality versus their propaganda
sometimes we think the world knows our
story but they don't Comics are one of
the tools to reach them Israelis have
made it into International Studios like
Marvel with comics and manage to take
Israeli superheroes global
first and skin generation refugees could
turn home
pinning their hopes on younger
Palestinians
I have a very strong belief in this
generation they're very stubborn they'll
do anything for their rights they're
stronger than our generation for them
Palestine is historic Palestine
in Ramallah a demonstration took place
in the city center
thousands of people are gathering here
today and they say no matter how much
time has passed since the neckba they
will continue fighting for their rights
Palestinians Mark yet another year of
displacement another year under
occupation and yet another affirmation
of rights that seem to exist only in
words and not on the ground
the occupied West Bank
Palestinian president Mahmoud Abbas
commemorated nakbar at the U.N on Monday
and called for Israel to be suspended
from the international body it was the
first time the general assembly
officially recognized the event
Christian salimi reports from U.N
headquarters in New York
[Music]
Palestinians showed off their culture
and their resolve at the United Nations
on Monday when for the first time ever
the general assembly acknowledged the
nagpur
forcible displacement of 750 000
Palestinians in 1948 resulted in the
un's first and longest standing Refugee
crisis and one of its most intractable
conflicts historians took note of the
event I think it's symbolically
important that the United Nations mark
uh what became a tragedy for the
Palestinian people which was in part a
result of an action taken by the United
Nations
um there is still a narrative that's
pervasive in the American Media and in
American
politics whereby these things are are
somehow covered by Israel's security but
that margin is growing narrower and
narrower and on the international level
I think it's really it's really uh about
to disappear Israel called the event
anti-semitic and encouraged other
countries not to take part well this
biased organization is distorting its
own history I'm working to ensure that
member states understand that attending
this despicable event means destroying
any chance of Peace by adopting the
Palestinian narrative calling the
establishment of the state of Israel a
disaster
Palestinian president Mahmoud Abbas
addressed the Gathering for an hour and
called out the United States and Britain
for continuing to protect Israel with
their veto power in the security Council
they took part in rendering our people
victims when they decided to establish
another entity in our historic Homeland
for their own Colonial goals and
objectives Israel would not have
continued its hostilities and aggression
without the support it receives from
these two countries to this day
Palestine sign does not enjoy the rights
of a member State here at the United
Nations and two key Security Council
resolutions were never implemented one
creating two states Israel and Palestine
side by side the other establishing a
right of return for Palestinians to
their Homeland
a boss said Israel's acceptance as a
member state was conditioned on those
two resolutions and should be revoked
Christian salumi Al Jazeera the United
Nations
as Palestinians were preparing to Mark
the knock bar Israeli forces shot and
killed a Palestinian man during a riot
in nebulous in the occupied West Bank
[Music]
funeral was held for 22 year old Sala
Sabra the Israeli military said people
had held rocks and explosives and fired
at its forces more than 150 Palestinians
have been killed in the occupied
territory so far this year